now one thing we need to hear more about
from GOP Presidential candidates is what
they're going to do about the gross
overreach of the justice department
so they've targeted Christians parents
you name it they've done it now anyone
who's rattling the cage or making noise
about the establishment the bind
Administration perceives it as a threat
now they're going after Elon Musk again
the doj is suing his company SpaceX over
discriminatory practices because the
company will not hire Asylum Seekers or
refugees
now this isn't something musk has ever
hidden he's been saying it for years in
fact he says it's all because of one
thing
when are you going to hire people from
other countries than the US
unfortunately it this is not up to us so
the US government regulations
um
uh well they make um
getting a job in the U.S hard as it is
just getting a job as hard as it is but
if you're working on Rocket technology
that's considered an advanced weapons
technology
so even a normal work visa isn't
sufficient so I want to be clear this is
not some out of some
desire of SpaceX to just hire people
with with green cards it's it's because
we're not allowed to do anything else
the government says that he's wrong that
musk can hire asylees and refugees to
work on rocket and weapons technology I
personally don't think you should be
able to do that but they say That's the
Law now I want you to hear something
else that must said about this policy
I think this is not a wise thing for
this is not a wise policy for
you know for the U.S because there's so
many talented people all around the
world that we would love to have worked
at our company but unless the uh unless
they can somehow get a green card we
can't we're just we're legally prevented
from from hiring anyone
so musk is pretty liberal on this he's
not really with the populist camp on
this type of question but joining me now
is David sacks a close friend and former
colleague of Elon Musk he's also a
partner at craft Ventures and co-host of
the all in podcast now David setting
aside uh the angles disagreement with
musk on who should be working on Rocket
technology
why do you think the doj filed this
lawsuit is it really a principal
disagreement about the statute itself or
something else going on
well Laura I think first of all they're
basically saying that SpaceX is hiring
too many Americans they believe that
SpaceX should have hired fewer American
citizens and green card holders and
hired more refugees but the really crazy
thing about this is as you heard in your
video uh it's not like Elon wanted to
have that policy what he said is that
they were required to there's a law
called itar which is the international
traffic and arms regulation act which
controls uh the it controls how
companies that are involved in
manufacturing rockets and advanced
weapons have to deal with classified
information and it was widely understood
this was the belief of the entire
industry not just SpaceX and Elon that
they could not hire uh basically foreign
Nationals that they could only hire
American citizens and green card holders
it wasn't until April of this year that
the doj issued what they called a
clarification saying that these
companies had to hire
again refugees and asylees as considered
on the category of U.S persons and now
they're going back and and they want to
make it retroactive to 2008 through 2022
so pre-clarification they want to
basically say that SpaceX is liable for
those 15 years before they issued this
clarification yeah I want people to know
what this entails as David referenced
there okay the doj wants SpaceX
to pay back pay including interest and
all other relief available to each
individual discriminated
against who was actually qualified
I mean that's got to be a not an
insignificant amount of money David and
again this seems um
this seems really punitive at this point
this does not seem like a fair
application of clarified statutory
language right
yeah I mean the remedies here are
unprecedented first of all they want
SpaceX to pay the doj Civil penalties
but more than that like you said they
want to go back and say that anybody who
was screened out you have to pay them
lost wages for all the years since they
were screened out so essentially what
the government is assuming is that
somebody who was screened out in this
way definitely would have been hired
definitely would have stayed at SpaceX
for all of those years and was entitled
to all this back pay as we know SpaceX
is has a very high bar for hiring it's a
very difficult place to get jobs and
people who can't get jobs there can get
jobs and lots of other places so they're
just assuming these incredibly Draconian
remedies
yeah I don't think they'd be applying to
any other company uh that's the kicker I
think he's being targeted for who he is
what he believes about free speech and
for of course uh X formerly known as
Twitter that's what this is about David
thank you for your insights on this hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else